Knitting socks in the round will eliminate
a seam in the foot of your sock.
Before we get started,
please be familiar with the settings for
knitting in the round on your machine.
You'll be slipping stitches on one bed
while knitting on the opposite bed.
Also, you must swatch for your sock
in the round. The gauge will differ
from knitting on the single bed.
Start by casting on and
knitting your ribbing.
Unless you want to hand-manipulate your
ribbing, you'll be knitting the rubbing
flat and then switching
to circular knitting.
When the ribbing is complete, transfer
all the stitches to the main bed.
Drop the Ribber.
Now you can knit one
plain row if you'd like.
Put half of the stitches in hold
and scrap off the other half.
Notice that I'm scrapping off opposite
the carriage, the working yarn is
available for the next steps.
This eliminates a yarn tail.
Remove your cast on comb and weigths..
Fold the scrapped edge and carefully rehang
the stitches on the main bed,
doubling up the stitches.
Remove the waste
yarn.
Add some weight.
Raise your ribber and carefully transfer
one stitch from each
needle down to the Ribber.
Yes, this is tedious.
There is no shortcut.
And before you start knitting,
carefully examine the stitches,
make sure that they're all picked up,
no stitches have dropped
and none are crossing the beds.
Set your carriages for circular knitting.
Slipping on one bed,
knitting on the other,
and continue knitting in the round.